Contact lenses have been a revolution for many people.
Unintrusive, easy to use and comparatively affordable.
But they just, well, they kind of sit there, doing their job.
Wouldn't it be cool if they could give you some kind of super eyesight?
Well, now they can, thanks to the Swiss Federal Institute of Technology.
The organization has developed lenses with a three times optical zoom,...
...allowing the users to focus in on hard-to-spot details with eagle-eyed precision.
They do have to be worn with special polarizing glasses...
...which activate or deactivate the zoom, and for the moment,...
...they're only good enough to aid the eyesight of people with degenerative conditions.